vous restez avec nous on va parler du
basket à présent pour conclure cette
page sports oui tout à fait avec jean
christophe bouillon bonsoir dont vous
êtes le président de du club de basket
de basket attrape la saison nationale
devient de vient de reprendre et une
première défaite malgré une belle fin de
saison dernière donc face face au mans
c'est simple fait qu'elle est quel
regard portez vous sur ce sursaut
surprise sur ce premier match
écoutez normal au vu de notre
préparation qui a été un petit peu
difficile parce que
beaucoup de fins trois joueurs voire
quatre sont blessés donc on pas pu
participer à ce match
donc maintenant on n'est qu'en début de
saison il reste encore 25 journées de
championnat bon il faut il faut attendre
maintenant on ne perd que 2 que de six
points au mans pour une équipe qui est
promu cette année en nationale 2 mais
qui avait l avantage de jeu dans sa
salle pour cette première journée donc
attendre un petit peu aussi comme petite
déception d'avoir perdu on voit des
images de la saison dernière la saison
passée vous aviez a terminé sur les
chapeaux de roue vous étiez quasiment
l'accession à la division supérieure
était quasiment acquise
qu'est-ce qui manque là pour se remettre
en route mais tout simplement parce
qu'il ya une partie des joueurs qui nous
ont quittés et puis à peu près quatre à
cinq joueurs nous ont quittés dons qu'il
a eu il ya eu un recrutement de fait cet
été et lors de ce recrutement justement
dans les quatre recrues vous avez trois
joueurs qui sont blessés depuis trois
semaines donc ça a été difficile de
créer une cohésion dans le dans le jeu
donc le coach a fait ce qu'il pouvait
avec les moyens du bord et puis de ses
récurrents quand même pour traquer
chaque année les blessés ont commencé la
saison sur les moments clés c'est
souvent blessé tout seul c'est tous les
sports là je fais le tour un peu toutes
les équipes ce week-end toutes les
équipes avaient toujours un ou deux
blessés c'est normal y'a une grosse
grosse préparation estivale et puis
c'est le sport le basket est un sport
qui est très très difficile pour les
tout ce qui est jeu nous aux
articulations donc forcément il ya des
petits bobos mais c'est ce qui est
important c'est que ce soit pas très
grave et qu'on puisse les récupérer
rapidement et alors du coup pour pour
cette nouvelle saison
les ambitions c'est quoi c'est le
maintien c'est on essaye de retenter de
playoffs comme l'année dernière les
play-offs
la dernière c'était pas un objectif ça
c'est ça s'est tracé comme ça parce que
je rappelle quand même que mettre des
sommes on était relégable dernière est
donc s'est trouvé qu'on a pu faire un
parcours exceptionnel de mois de
décembre au moins d'avril de cette année
je vais faire comme les amis du rugby de
saint quentin on va on va jouer le
maintien
alors c'est pas une c'est peu dire où je
vous fais c'est pas de risque il faut il
faut être un des deux clubs qui jouent
le maintien oui oui bref c'est ici un
coiffeur en forme et il faut aussi être
réalistes et que si on veut être dans la
cour des grands il faut avoir en avoir
les moyens
donc aujourd'hui on il faut être
raisonnable et raisonnée et puis on va
on va tout faire pour déjà essayé au
mois de décembre d'être dans une
position un peu plus de maintenu et puis
après si un coup à faire je sais que le
coach et les joueurs ne manqueront pas
l'occasion justement vous parlez de
moyens on sait que les moyens
budgétaires a attrapé son sont limités
par rapport à d'autres clubs de national
ce qui fait que vous devez recruter un
peu malins ont du coup ça limite aussi
les ambitions sur la cause de ça oui tu
te fais maintenant c'est je crois aussi
que si avec eux que l'argent qui était
la seule vérité pour être au niveau ça
serait maintenant c'est vrai qu'il est
évident que quand je vois les armadas
que l'équipe qu'on va rencontrer samedi
soir qui est l'équipe de berck c'est
pratiquement trois fois le budget de
notre équipe notre club donc c'est du
club de trappes
c'est quoi cette année on va avoisiner
les 240 mille euros pour l'ensemble du
club
je dis bien pour l'ensemble du club il
ya 270 licenciés il ya une quinzaine d'
équipe
un club comme celui de berck que vous
allez rencontrer à domicile ce week end
bf et reuters son vouloir
donner les chiffres précis je sais que
ça vaut un budget qui avoisine à 400000
euros que pour l'équipe première du club
comment ça s'explique pourquoi ils
entendent différence d'un club à l'autre
je crois qu'il ya une volonté peut-être
politique ou partenariat qui est plus
forte en tout cas que dans nos régions
et puisqu'il peut paraître paradoxal
parce que pour connaître un petit peu
berck et connaître saint quentin en
yvelines je crois qu'on n'est pas dans
la même cour tout cas au niveau des
entreprises et que c'est toujours moi
c'est bon c'est bon cheval de bataille
l'engagement et l'investissement des
entreprises et notamment des chaises sur
ceux qui sont sur saint quentin c'est
regrettable qui est pas n'est pas
possibilité de pouvoir capter c'est ce
soutien là parce que aujourd'hui on peut
pas remettre en cause et le soutien de
la ville de trappes et le soutien de la
communauté d'agglomération qui sont sans
faille qui naissaient les partenaires
privés oui parce que vous avez mal à
convaincre ou et puis j'ai entendu parlé
tout à l'heure du du conseil général
fois que le conseil général aussi c'est
pareil s'est totalement désengagé de du
sport de haut niveau sur sur le bassin
saint quentinois puisque jeu voire même
le département du 78 donc je crois aussi
que de ce côté-là irait il faudrait
peut-être un petit peu plus de
reconnaissance notamment sur le sport
sur le sport dans les yvelines très bien
donc prochain match ce week-end face à
l'avenir de berck attrape absolument 20
heures gymnase paul mallet on vous
attend nombreux l'équipe a besoin de
votre soutien et je sais qu'on peut
compter sur les supporters
merci beaucoup aux gens qui salueront
d'être venu sur le plateau de télé fils
ce soir également à vous d'être revenue
sur le plateau nous présenter toutes ses
médailles et toutes les distractions que
vous avez pu recevoir et encore c'est
qu'une infime partie en a beaucoup en
coulisses on les a vus il ya un an elles
sont nombreuses
merci beaucoup je n'envie nommé entonné
quelques résultats à présent pour
conclure cette page sports oui tout à
fait ce week-end avait avait lieu
l'ekiden c'est ce marathon par équipe
créée au japon lors de la première
guerre mondiale
soixante équipes de 6 coureurs étaient
au départ à la base de saint quentin en
yvelines dimanche c'est le galli
athletic club qui l'emporté en deux
heures 43 minutes le smac le club de
montigny-le-bretonneux a terminé sur la
troisième marche du podium
à noter la très belle performance de
l'équipe féminine de l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin elles ont
franchi la ligne d'arrivée en septième
position
notre résultat également dans cette page
de sport du football
oui du football on va commencer par les
dames
les footballeuses de montigny se sont
imposés à dijon sur le score de 2 buts à
1 les josine montay ne remonte à la 5e
place de leur poule de nationale 2 à 4
points du leader
hénin beaumont qui rencontreront le 7
octobre prochain que cela soit aussi en
championnat ou en coupe le début de
saison est synonyme de victoire à
l'aller montigny handball les josine
montay ne se sont imposés face à aulnay
sur le score de 26 à 25 pour le compte
du second tour de la coupe de france
belle performance donc car le club
francilien d'aulnay évolue une division
au dessus des genoux ni monteyne et puis
donner un résultat très rapidement tout
d'abord en rugby et puis également en
baseball les playoffs pour les cougars
oui en rugby un autre club du
département fait aussi un début de
saison tonitruant c'est le rugby club de
deux plaisirs les plaisirs oies ont
battu orléans 21 à 10 invaincu cette
saison les bleus et jaunes sont en tête
de leur poule de fédérale 3 lors de la
prochaine journée le père c se déplace
chez le 7e beauvais merci anthony non le
baseball
oui pas du ps je vous fais part les
services google a fait pas les oublier
les couverts ils sont en playoffs
malheureusement ça s'est pas très bien
passé ce week-end pour nos joueurs de
montigny face aux squales de vauréal
ils ont perdu en deux manches 14 et 22
12 mais ils peuvent encore se qualifier
pour la finale du championnat de
national une à condition de battre
dunkerque dimanche
on vous retrouve lundi prochain pour un
point complet sur le sport et il sera
question de deux marathons puisque atv
fils on a une réaction plutôt sportive
notre journaliste alice gastines la
spécialiste économique de la rédaction à
se faire dresser la liste sport tu vas
faire voilà va me seconde et et va
participer donc au semi marathon entre
paris et versailles nous la suivrons et
en exclusivité pour téléphiles elle
viendra sur notre plateau pendant la
chronique sport lundi prochain a
témoigné lundi prochain en direct à 18h
merci anthony merci à nos invités dans
un instant on va parler du d'une belle
opération manger bio manger solidaire
c'est le créneau des crédos pardon des
jardins de cocagne son directeur va me
rejoindre
juste après ce reportage consacré à une
opération de prévention à l'attention
des motards les motards qui représente
un quart des tués sur les routes
à gauche interrogation surprise sur le
code de la route
pas si simple après des années de
conduite jeudi dernier 30 participants
se sont prêtés au jeu du rallye moto
touristique à elancourt
une journée organisée par la police
nationale sur place l'ambiance est bon
enfant
mais l'enjeu crucial alors cette journée
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'une action de
prévention action de sensibilisation
puisque sur nos routes
comme sur l'ensemble des routes de au
plan national les usagers de deux-roues
payé un très lourd tribut à
l'accidentologie
donc le but de cette journée et les
sensibiliser d'une part aux dangers de
la route mais aussi c'est le but des
ateliers qui est derrière moi
actuellement à la maniabilité à
l'aisance sur leurs motos après un rally
de 80 kilomètres à travers le
département
l'atelier de maniabilité c'est l'ultime
épreuve solidaire la police montre
l'exemple
au programme slalom manoeuvre équilibre
et anticipation une piqûre de rappel
nécessaire avec toutes les associations
qui sont sur place sur la sécurité
routière enfin il y a
et les sapeurs pompiers ça nous montre
aussi les dangers on peut rencontrer sur
la route
donc il nous donne pas mal d'indications
aussi sur les les tenues qu'on doit
mettre on ne pas mettre ce qu'on nous
dit pas forcément chez les tous les
revendeurs de d'accessoires auto moto je
trouve ça très intéressant par contre
ça manque il ya passé deux journées de
formation comme ça d'animation pour que
selon moi ça touche suffisamment de
monde et que les gens comprennent que
c'est important de pouvoir maîtriser la
moto sur la route quoi c'est
indispensable
on est je pense qu'on est jamais
chevronnés on a toujours des choses à
apprendre et personnellement j'apprends
toujours des choses sur la route
l'opération lancée en 1998 et renouvelée
chaque année dans le département
le dernier bilan de la sécurité routière
dans les yvelines en 2011 enregistre 20
morts de conducteurs de deux roues un
chiffre trop élevé et auquel les
autorités souhaitent mettre un frein